[Music]
GMA on the six you'll see you know who
your partner is yet club Pretty Little
Liars stars Sasha Pieterse uh is headed
to the Dancing with the Stars ballroom
she spilled all of the details to ET
actually they asked me like three or
four years ago and I I wasn't able to do
it scheduling was a nightmare and they
said that they'd come back around and
they came back around which was so
awesome and this is the 25th season so
extra sparkles extra everything which is
so fun so I'm really glad to be a part
of this season part of the ballroom
journey are you most looking forward to
I mean my parents were dancers they were
professional dancers that's actually one
of the reasons we emigrated to America
so I think that part of it I'm really
proud to be able to be a part of that
and kind of what they started and I
don't mind my mom cried when I told her
she's beyond excited but I think just
kind of proving to myself that I can do
something totally different something
that I'm not used to it's definitely not
in my comfort zone actually somewhere to
the kitchen the fact that it's live I'm
losing my mind like I'm good at
memorizing lines but memorizing dances
it's gonna be a challenge so yeah it's
me fun I feel like your fans are going
to flip I think yeah they're gonna go
they're gonna love it they're gonna go
crazy actually we've already named our
team our team name is be 18 because
hello the best name that you could have
chosen like we're gonna do this we're
gonna get that Mary Ball will you be
dancing to the PLL theme song at any
point I never thought about that that
would be fun you have a dream song in
your head of what you would want to do
on the show
I don't know I'm actually miss
predicament because I have to give them
music choices like I have to tell them
what I want to do and because I grew up
around I was an only child I grew up
around tons of music cuz my parents were
dancers I mean I love Queen I love ABBA
I love Eminem and dr. Dre like I love so
many different things so I think you're
gonna get a good taste of all of that
and our dances and you don't have any
dancing experience you know your parents
we're dancers no I mean I'm gonna dub
did ballet when I was three I don't
think that really counts I got rhythm I
think that's in my blood but
no dance experience other than that I'm
really excited sasha is currently hard
at work on her blog and her upcoming
flick honored alongside Karrueche Tran
and Megan ranks
she says they'll be supporting her so
maybe I'll be in the ballroom cheering
you on okay
[Music]